I asked you to divide this guy in here
by that we've got an answer we got a
remainder okay this is just to get your
head back in the space today we're going
to look at ways of generalizing what is
happening here because this is a very
specific example a single polynomials
have being divided by a single other
thing with a single answer etc we want
to be able to make some statements that
are true of a whole bunch of different
things different polymers that we can
work with okay to help us do that we
need some extra language and I want to
remind you like this is not a new stuff
okay this thing that you're dividing by
the thing you're dividing by what's this
called does it remember it's the divisor
it's the divisor okay since it's the
divisor let's call it D of X okay D 4
divides up this here this polynomial the
one being divided by what's it called
it's called the dividend very good quite
an uncommon word we hardly use it I mean
it's sort of been taken over by its own
financial meaning nowadays the dividend
is the polynomial you started with so
the polynomial you start with is usually
called P I might as well call it back
because I can't call it D anyway because
I've already used that letter ok what
you get left with at the top is your
answer which is comprised of two
components there's this part over here
which is the starts with a Q it's the
question
so I guess we can call that Q of X okay
and that leaves the final piece the
remainder right now a quick note I've
said let's call each of these pieces D
of X P of X Q of X and then there's this
number here but for those of you who
were faithful and we're here on
Wednesday morning you might remember
this remainder isn't always just a
number it's not always just a number in
this case it's a number because I was
dividing through by something linear but
if my divisor was not linear if my
divisor was say a quadratic okay if I've
divided this cubic by you know x squared
plus X plus 3 I could have done that
that would have been fine if you have a
quadratic divisor your remainder might
not be just the number what might it be
it might have some X terms in there
right what we saw was the degree here is
going to be one more than the degree
here okay or another way of saying it
either the degree of your remainder is
always 1 less than the degree of your
divisor okay so therefore this here the
remainder is itself also a polynomial
right in this case it's just the
constant polynomial okay so D P Q and R
these are the pieces in here right what
I want us to do is just um write it
again but in general terms not for this
is specific example right but generally
speaking we always have the divisor over
here right we have the original
polynomial the dividend underneath and
then what you get left with is your
quotient and your remainder okay now
what I'd like us to do is look at this
thing here and make a statement about
all of this from this working and we'll
come up with an equivalent statement
over here if I've divided this cubic by
this linear thing and gotten this
quadratic in this remainder then I can
say that the original polynomial P x
cubed minus 4x squared plus 2x minus 1
it equals two I can say in terms of all
these other pieces right in fact I'm
even going to say in order it's the
divisor multiplied by the quotient and
then how does the remainder come into
play plus the remainder which in this
case is minus 17 okay so I can state
that in general terms for any
polynomials being divided in the
following way the original polynomial
pay what it equals to is let's write
this carefully the divisor times the
quotient plus the remainder said okay
divisor question remainder or happy
let's make that up statement again about
the oops wrong color about the degrees
because that's going to become quite
important in a second if this divisor
here has a degree of you can have any
degree comment right let's say degree in
what that will mean is the remainder
over here has a degree of what yeah one
less will be n minus one okay
so I want to look at the specific
example and you'll see why we're doing
this later of when we have a linear
divisor we have this a whole lot it's
very very common it's the most common
thing we have to do we only show you how
to do quadratics and cubic divisors just
because we can but it's not that useful
okay
if I have a divisor that is a monic and
linear these are the most common ones we
deal with okay where a is a constant
then I can rewrite this statement with
some interesting sort of consequences
right I can say that P of X is the
divisor which is X minus a times the
quotient and because I have a divisor
that is degree 1 what will be the degree
of my remainder it'll be 1 minus 1 which
is 0 which is exactly what we sort of
are used to getting you see that that's
a polynomial of degree 0 okay so since
it's just a number its degree 0 I'm
gonna say plus ah and I don't need to
say any excess here it's actually
independent of X it's just a constant so
this guy here is degree 0 okay now watch
what happens I can really quickly find
out what the remainder of something is
rather than by going through this whole
long process you can see the remainder
is the last thing you find out if I want
to if it's useful to me spoilers it will
be if it's useful to me I can find out
the remainder immediately without going
through this whole process by making X
equal to a watch if I substitute in x
equals a right this is just using
function or function notation right then
what happens well I'm gonna put in an a
everywhere I see an X I see it two
places I see it there once and I see it
there twice that ok and then of course
the remainder is independent of X so
just sits out there inside well
this is just zero to zero so what I find
is that P of a equals the remainder
right so what this means is if I come
back over here this original example
that we did right
if this thing is my X minus a what is a
in this case look carefully
so yeah it's negative three isn't it
because it's X minus negative three will
give me this divisor okay so if this is
P of X and if I put in P of negative
three let's just quickly crunch this
number right what's that going to be
negative three all cubed is going to be
negative 27 minus for lots of nine plus
two lots of negative three minus one
minus 27 minus thirty-six minus six
minus one looks like minus seventy to me
yes which was rather quicker than going
through all of this if that was the
thing that I was really interested in
now of course you're going to ask the
question why would I ever be interested
in the remainder I'm gonna get to that
in about four minutes okay but first
let's take this because this thing here
this really simple thing this is what we
call the remainder theorem if you want
to get to the remainder rapidly of a
monic linear divisor like this then all
you have to do is put in the appropriate
value and the remainder just pops out
okay